[Music]
and welcome to hannity and tonight we
are broadcasting
from the south texas airport we're only
a few miles from the u.s mexico border
where for the entire hour we will be
joined by the 45th president of the
united states
donald j trump along with the texas
governor greg
abbott and we'll also ask the president
about some other questions other issues
of the day but
of course donald trump no stranger to
the southern border after
his predecessor barack obama left him
with an absolute mess
president trump he made it his top
priority to secure
our nation's borders and that means
enforced laws protect our sovereignty
protect our borders
he restricted asylum cases he stopped
obama's disastrous catch and release
program
he instituted what was known as the stay
in mexico policy
for new migrants he negotiated deals
with several
latin american countries to expedite the
deportation of illegal immigrants
he successfully built nearly 500 miles
of new border wall
and this is important because he told
migrants around the world
do not come to america illegally he was
very clear
don't make this dangerous trip don't
send your children
unaccompanied through mexico across the
rio grande and the desert
into the border make no mistake
president trump's actions and rhetoric
were as effective as they've ever been
for example look at this headline quote
trump immigration policy showing results
with the illegal border crossings
plummeting
here's another from axios illegal border
crossings continue to fall
as u.s enforces asylum agreements
and another quote like them or not trump
policies
are reducing illegal immigration now
sadly just after joe biden was sworn in
he reversed almost all of president
trump's border policies
now you might remember this it was after
biden and harris they told migrants oh
come to america come seek asylum in
america
on the campaign trail biden literally
telling migrants to surge the border
let's play the videotape what i would do
as president
is several more things because things
have changed i would in fact make sure
that there is we immediately surge to
the border
all those people are seeking asylum they
deserve to be heard that's who we are
where a nation says if you want to flee
and you're feeding oppression
you should come president sippy cup
seemed a little more alert back then in
2019
now the results of biden's border surge
have been catastrophic
in february illegal immigration more
than tripled
a hundred thousand ill illegal
immigrants
apprehended in february 170 000 in march
178 000 in april and a whopping 180
000 in may and by the way that's only
the number of people we caught
there are record-setting numbers a
30-year high for illegal immigration and
get this
more unaccompanied minors are now
crossing our southern border than ever
before
it is a crisis of a monumental scale
border patrol agents i spent a lot of
time with them today they are
overwhelmed overworked
dangerous cartels they are making
millions in human trafficking
and taking advantage of the fact that
all the resources
are being used to basically process
people
illegally into the country that gives
free rang
rain to the drug dealers the human
traffickers
we know where 90 percent of america's
heroin comes from
our southern border we know the fentanyl
crisis
we know the number of deaths that happen
each and every week about 300
all across america because of these
drugs migrant facilities now
operating at over 300 capacity
and with the help of the biden
administration illegal immigrants
are being relocated all over the u.s
in exchange for a mere promise to show
up to a late court date
if that date is even given out this
crisis has no end in sight
but instead of reinstating the
successful policies of donald trump
well joe biden he punted all border
duties to his vice president kamala
harris
who for months and months flat out
refused to even visit
when she finally decided to make a stop
in texas
well she had time to stop by el paso for
a couple of hours on her way to los
angeles
one big problem el paso is not where the
current crisis
is happening it's happening right here
where we are
and according to a new harvard harris
poll voters now rate kamala harris's
performance on immigration as poor
the same poll shows that 68 percent of
voters
believe the biden administration that
they are to blame for this surge
61 percent also blaming biden for the
surge of
unaccompanied minors 55 percent think
donald trump's border policies
never should have been undone 80 percent
think illegal immigration is a serious
issue
but it's not clear that the biden
administration is able or willing to
secure our southern border
actions they speak louder than words and
to that end
during his presidency donald trump
visited the southern border
all by himself six times joe biden has
never visited
not once just think about that now
tonight we're here of the crowd of great
americans including many friends of
president trump i see my friend louie
gorman is in the crowd
congressman billy long he is here with
us governor abbott will join us on this
stage
but first joining us right now right
here in south texas
the 45th president of the united states
donald j
trump
wow thank you thank you
everybody
thank you thank you
thank you everybody thank you
what a group
thank you everybody
[Music]
[Music]
okay i just have one minor complaint
i did not get that reaction when i came
out
thank you mr president great to have you
hi sean
boy you know i guess one question um if
i asked this crowd
uh do you miss them yet i think i know
the answer
from day one the day you and melania
trump came down that escalator
you talked about securing our country's
borders you had to fight hard
to get the money to build 500 miles of
wall yeah to stay in mexico policy
you built the wall you ended catch and
release
now we see what's happening your
reaction to all of it well there has
never been a better time
six months ago and there's never been a
worse time we had the tightest security
you could come into our country legally
but you know what else we were stopping
massive amounts of drugs
human traffickers bad bad people
criminals they're emptying their jails
into our country you know other
countries are emptying their jails into
our country
we never had it better and now we've
never had it worse in the history of our
country
i just saw with the governor the
lieutenant governor
we're with ken we're with a whole group
i think the largest contingent of
congress
congress people ever at the border
from what i understand i think they're
mostly here too by the way i see them
a lot of them right in front of me but
we had the largest
we have the we even have doc ronnie
right so my doctor in the white house
who became a congressman
by the way ronnie would you mind giving
joe a cognitive test
uh president sippy cup i don't know how
well he's going to do but anyway i won't
get you in trouble with his comments
we aced it i think i can say that i aced
it did he get one he didn't get one
question wrong did he
30 out of 30. wow
and they did get a little more difficult
after you got by 15 i would say but
i heard the first three questions are is
it a giraffe or an elephant right
well you know that's what the fake news
does they take the first two or three
questions and they put that
and they put them in but let me tell you
they would not get those last 15 rights
certainly not the last 10 that i can
tell you but
anyway but we have uh we have a border
that's very bad right now and very
dangerous for our country
and uh fortunately we have a lot of
great people in texas in particular the
job they're doing
you know what's fascinating all of a
sudden
biden is blaming you i know for the
current crisis
and it's called misinformation that's
fake they've done it for
five years six years russia russia
russia
and i told you the story i told sean the
story i'd go around people would say
sir do you know anything about russia
this is what i'm running years ago
i'd say no no a month later do you know
anything about russia
another guy comes up sir you know
anything but then i get a call from
virginia you know anything about russia
i said what's going on with russia
and was the russia hoax that was
misinformation
now they're saying it was the republican
party that wanted to defund the police
you hear that billy billy's not a big
defunder of the police i can tell you
the republican party wants to defund the
police this just started yesterday
i don't know how they're getting away
with that one but all you have to do is
you know the good thing with you you
take the old clips there's no idea
i played the greatest hits last night
sir yes i played them all
you know when when you look at what else
is happening too
and it's interesting that states like
florida and south dakota and
many others they're offering texas and
arizona support now that's right
and their law enforcement because in the
dark of night
they're taking illegal immigrants flying
them into these states
and now the states are responsible
that's right for food and shelter and
health care and education they can't
the states don't even know they're
coming they bring people in and the
states don't even know they say here you
take in this
it's an allotment it's called an
allotment and the governor's republican
governors
are by the way you look at the well-run
states it's all done by
for the most part republican governors
all of them
in terms of crime in terms of everything
else now we have great republican
governors we really do
so the the policies that have been
reversed
joe hasn't come to the border you've
been here many times
kamala really didn't come to the border
it seemed like a photo op to me
what would you want them to know that
they don't know or maybe they do know
and they don't seem to care about
well kamala wouldn't have come if she
didn't hear i was coming i was invited
by the governor
and i said yes and i said yes
to my honor because we were very proud
of the job we did nobody's ever done the
job that we've done we built over
now i guess it's close to 500 miles of
wall
and we're going to build an extra 200
because we had money left over we're
going to do an extra 200
and nobody's ever done this and all he
had to do was go another two months and
the wall would have been totally
completed
and by the way they have to paint the
wall i'm going to give that job to brian
we have to paint great congressman
we have to paint the wall because it's
starting to rust
it's supposed to be painted and they
don't even want to paint the wall it's
so disgraceful two more months
everything would have been completed
and they said just like with the
keystone pipeline they're not going to
do it 48 000 jobs out the window and an
environmental pipeline much better than
other forms of transportation for the
product so
it's when you look at what's happening
and inflation
is going to be the killer of them all
because inflation is going to destroy
our country
the border is going to destroy our
country i want to get to all that
[Applause]
if if donald trump and we had a hard
time
getting video there were even
congressmen and i know louie was part of
it i know that
senator ted cruz was down here and many
others i'm
not ignoring a lot of you and i know
that
if it wasn't for them they wouldn't
allow our cameras in the new cages they
were building for kids
now in 2018 they accused you of putting
children in cages
it turns out the video was from 2014.
you were not president now joe biden is
building these cages in the middle of a
pandemic
high rate of positive cases of covet
kids living on top of each other imagine
for a second
what would it be what would the press
have been like and democrats been saying
if you had built these new cages which
they're building all over here
but i really had that because in 2018
and even after 2018 they came out with
these horrible pictures
and somebody came up and said well it
was the contractor
he said but i built those cages in 2014
during obama's
administration and it wasn't trump it
was obama that built those cages got a
little bit lucky
and after we said that all of a sudden
the whole cage thing went away but now
they're building them again because
there's so many kids coming in
and you know many of the kids are on
suicide watch something we've never
heard of think of this
it's so miserable it's so hot it's like
hell
i mean i just walked i will say although
right now i think it was hotter in new
york than it was in texas
it was 101 degrees in new york this was
like i got here was like cool
but um their kids are on suicide watch
think of that
it's uh it's a terrible thing look at 90
percent of the heroin
crosses that southern border now
fentanyl we've had the two biggest
fentanyl busts
in the history of the country we're
losing over 300 americans a week
in some cases more the worst thing of
all a sheriff just said at a meeting we
had we had a round table and
these sheriffs are incredible the law
enforcement in texas and other places
and he said and i didn't even know this
he said for the end of our
administration we had fentanyl
virtually stopped now he said it's
coming in at levels that we've never
seen before we had it stopped it was
very tough to get it was nasty
getting through our border especially
with almost the 500 miles of wall
it was nasty to get through and these
people and i gave them the right to stop
people
now they're not even allowed to talk to
people you're not allowed to talk to
people
but again people coming in is bad
prisoners and real serious criminals
of the murderers walking in i'll never
forget
i'm watching of all places cnn okay
this was a short-term watch and they had
a reporter
no this is before i can't hear you
what'd you say
well now their ratings are down 79
i'm watching cnn and a woman reporter is
asking what did you do what did you do
it's very famous lip and this guy looks
at her murderer she said what
murder and she immediately they cut it
off the camera that was the end of that
but we have thousands of hardened
criminals like we don't even have in
this country practically ms-13 we took
them out by the thousands
you know i told the story just now we
had the border
the three countries primarily guatemala
honduras and el salvador
ms-13 and other criminals were coming
out and they wouldn't take them back in
the obama administration they refused to
take them back
they would have planes on the runway so
when our plane would want to land they
couldn't land
they would stop the buses and i said
well do we pay these countries any money
they wouldn't take them back at the
beginning of my the three countries i
know the heads of the three countries
they're smart they're very street
smart dictators okay but they're very
street
smart people and i like them they like
me we get along but you know it's like
business is business you know they're
evil but they're not dogs i don't know
they're not look we got along i said how
much do we pay those countries 500
million dollars sir but what does that
have to do with it sir
has everything to do don't pay any more
we didn't pay
and then i was called stop payment
now it's called we stop payment you ever
hear the term we stop payment and we
stop payment
and then the next day i get a call from
all three president you stop payment no
more money coming into
the three countries i said that's right
you're not taking your criminals back
but we would love to nobody asked us
properly we would
have to take our we would love to take
ms-13 back
they are wonderful people i said fine we
sent them back by the thousands they
took them
yeah by the thousands but nobody's ever
done that before
nobody ever did it before
do you have a theory an idea because i i
really can't think of one except
that you know i i think in years gone by
i would argue that there were
republicans that wanted illegal
immigration because they get cheap labor
and i think that democrats want to
provide something of great worth
which would be amnesty citizenship and
you have rhinos you do have rhinos look
they're right a lot of rhinos out there
sometimes i may say the rhinos of these
people you don't have any writers in
this or we can
we probably have 45 congressmen here and
women
uh you don't have any rhinos in this
group but you have rhinos i call them
weak
republicans they walk into the white
house i've been watching for four weeks
now they walk in
they meet biden he doesn't know what the
hell's happening
they meet by he's sitting and they're
talking about
infrastructure and finally they walk out
they have a deal
and the deal is a terrible deal but it's
a deal
and it sort of reminds me of england a
long time ago we have a deal
we have a deal you remember the deal
they made with germany not too good
that didn't work out too well right but
they reminded me they
they walk out we have a deal we have a
deal and it was the typical names there
were a couple of good ones in there i
don't know how they got roped in but
they walk in
so they have a deal and then biden
canceled the deal because the radical
left said you can't make that deal that
deal's no good we want to spend six
trillion dollars
well they would back door everything
they didn't get in the deal
they would back door through the
reconciliation process well we need
better leadership at the senate level
you need better leadership we need
somebody better than mitch mcconnell
yeah mitch mcconnell can no longer do
the job when you
you know it was a very difficult process
because i was covering it every night
and that was
the congress was not assisting you for
the money
for the border wall which was a
signature promise that you made yeah
in 2016. but you found a way to get the
money
and build the wall so what i did is i
got a big military budget approved and i
took it out of the military because the
way i look at it this is
defense i spent two and a half years
winning lawsuits we won all of the
lawsuits there were 11.
we won every one of them i started
building the wall it's two months
from completion and this guy stops it
yeah
and that's tragic and it's dangerous for
texas and arizona and every other state
it's tragic all right